después de un fin de semana de luchas
fraticidas entre la oposición turca hoy
mismo hace unos minutos la oposición que
se enfrentará al presidente Turco
recepta y erdogan en las elecciones del
14 de mayo haya aclarado quién será su
candidato para esas elecciones se trata
de que mal el presidente del principal
partido de la oposición el partido
republicano del pueblo un burócrata de
74 años no muy carismático Pero quien se
cree que puede ser el que abarque la
gran diversidad que hay dentro de la
oposición turca que abarca desde el
nacionalismo de la derecha turca hasta
partidos incluso comunistas y el partido
procurdo del gdp el tercero en
representación parlamentaria estos dos
partidos el comunista y el gdp el
partido por kurdon no están dentro de la
coalición opositora pero sí que aseguran
y lo han hecho Durante los últimos meses
que apoyarán a cualquier candidato que
se enfrente en contra del presidente
Turco renchev está ahí Perdón que ve
como las elecciones que se aproximan
será unas elecciones clave no sólo por
el terremoto que ocurrió hace hoy mismo
hace justo un mes que ha bajado la
Popular del presidente que ya estaba muy
baja de por sí Después de varios años de
una crisis inflacionaria tremenda en
Turquía inflación ahora mismo se
encuentra en torno a 55% oficial número
6 extraoficiales la situan mucho más
alta y es algo que se nota los turcos lo
notan en cada día que pasa